[Musique]
j'ai une bonne et une mauvaise nouvelle
qui tiennent en un chiffre 30 la bonne
d'abord par rapport à nos grands parents
nous bénéficions de trente années
d'espérance de vie en plus et pour la
majorité d'entre nous 30 ans de loisirs
et de repos plutôt une très bonne
nouvelle donc d'autant que la science
nous en promet chaque année davantage la
mauvaise maintenant 30% des personnes
âgées souffrent actuellement d'isolement
un million et demi de personnes sur 5
millions de plus de 60 ans trois cent
mille disent n'avoir eu aucun contact
avec un proche
trois cent mille personnes alors au delà
des statistiques
au-delà des chiffres l'important c'est
évidemment la réalité qu'il recouvre
votre réalité
et puis ma réalité moi ce lien entre
isolement et vieillissement
je les fais quand à 45 ans je suis allé
visiter ma grand mère dans sa maison de
retraite
alors quand je suis rentré quand je suis
entré dans cet établissement ça d'abord
été un grand choc
j'ai vu des personnes âgées très âgées
en fauteuil
alité scotché devant la télévision et
j'ai compris que c'était dans ce genre
d'établissement dans ce genre de lieu qu
on regroupait nos personnes âgées nos
vieux et que c'était la raison pour
laquelle on ne les voyait plus dans
l'espace public
elles sont pour nos enfants comme pour
nous à la fois loin de nos yeux
loin de nos consciences et par
conséquent loin de nos coeurs alors ma
petite mais ma grand mère
son sourire sa joie quand elle me voit
quand je rentre dans sa chambre on
commence par ouvrir une demi bouteille
de champagne tiède
quel sort de sa petite table de nuit et
puis on rigole on discute lui donne des
nouvelles de l'extérieur ce qui se passe
derrière les murs
et puis je la campagne 1 jusqu'à jusqu'à
la salle de réfectoire pour qu'elle
prenne son déjeuner elle me elle me fait
rencontrer ses voisines et là je suis
assez étonné puisque certaines veulent
me m'embrasser me toucher mais la
plupart sont murés dans le silence
et quand elle me regarde moi ce que je
vois c'est une grande solitude c'est ces
mêmes c'est au delà de ça c'est très
triste
alors je m'en vais parce que je ne suis
là qu'un visiteur et je laisse ma grand
mère dans sa maison de retraite
trente ans plus tôt mon autre grand mère
elle est morte chez nous à la campagne
dans la maison de mes parents
entourée de ses enfants de ses petits
enfants et moi j'étais ado j'adorais ma
grand mère j'adorais ma grand mère
pourtant son départ et puis son absence
ont semblé naturel sans violence sans
brutalité dans l'ordre des choses
ces deux expériences très différentes
mais qui sont deux émotions très fortes
évidemment je les ai encore au fond de
moi aujourd'hui et c'est sans doute la
raison pour laquelle je suis là devant
vous parce que c'est si facile de se
couper du monde avec l'âge c'est le
conjoint c'est les habits qui
disparaissent c'est les enfants qui
s'éloigne ou qui sont super occupée j'ai
pas si vous l'avez remarqué on est tous
super occupée alors quand en plus on est
isolé qu'on manque un peu de moyens
évidemment on se renferme encore
davantage sur soi pensez y quand vous
serez au contact des personnes âgées qui
vous sont proches
généralement avec l'âge la solitude peu
de moyens on demandait la personne pas
plus aux organismes sociaux c'est
souvent compliqué c'est décevant mais en
tout cas pas aux enfants et surtout pas
petits-enfants la maison de retraite
devient bien sûr l'évidence la solution
mais oui maman 20 en maison de retraite
qui sera bien avec des gens de ton âge
tu seras des activités et puis surtout
on s'inquiète ramoin
surtout on s'inquiétera - ouais mais
l'équation est pas si simple
parce que si votre maman ou la mienne
parce que c'est un sujet en ce moment ne
fait pas sienne cette décision elle
risque alors en quittant ce les repères
songe son logement son quartier et
éventuellement de s'isoler encore
davantage de s'abandonner à
l'institution et de vieillir moins
longtemps parfois beaucoup moins
longtemps et en tout cas avec une moins
belle qualité de vie alors remarqué
comme ça effectivement dans la plus à
s'inquiéter
et puis elle ne dérangera plus ce qu'on
entend parfois cette petite musique un
peu provoc un peu appel au secours
je peux partir maintenant comme ça ben
je dérangerait plus moi je pense depuis
longtemps que nous devrions en tout cas
que je devrais faire quelque chose
repenser cette relation avec nos aînés
imaginer des solutions qui leur
permettent de conserver des relations
sociales humaines qui sont tellement
importante pour le moral est donc pour
la santé j'ai eu l'intuition
il ya quelques années il ya une dizaine
d'années en discutant avec un ami
architecte que d'autres formes d'habitat
était possible il me dit effectivement
qu'en allemagne pays d'un vieillissement
accéléré de la population une forme
alternative d'habitants permettent aux
seniors de vieillir longtemps chez soi
très longtemps le plus longtemps
possible
ça m'intéresse alors j'y vais je me
rends avec lui près du lac de constance
et on visite des petites résidences des
petits ensembles résidentiels de 50 60
logements dans lesquels effectivement
cohabitent des jeunes des vieux des
familles parfois les personnes très
âgées et même certaines personnes qui
souffrent d'alzheimer et les personnes
les plus fragiles sont couvés
d'attention par les autres habitants
qu'ils sont eux mêmes aidés
dans cette relation par des personnels
dédiés qui facilite le lien entre les
résidents et entre les résidents et le
reste de la collectivité
les ag eux donnent de leur temps de leur
disponibilité de leurs expériences de
vie notamment aux plus jeunes et moi je
suis un peu pragmatique
ça me plaît parce que ça marche sam
scotch et puis ça mais mais aussi parce
que ça me fait évidemment remontée des
des émotions dont certaines que j'ai
partagé avec vous tout à l'heure alors
je rentre en france
j'ai une cinquantaine de grosse
cinquantaine d'années à l'époque et je
me dis voilà c'est ça que je veux faire
c'est ça que je vais faire j'ai été
consultant j'ai déjà monté de trois
boîtes
je vais créer une société qui va
réaliser des résidences dans lesquelles
le le rapport humain sera au coeur de
tout sera privilégiée et pour tous les
habitants quelles que soient leur âge et
quelles que soient leurs conditions
sociales alors je réunis autour de moi
progressivement des sociologues des
géographes une petite équipe avec eux on
va à la rencontre d'élus d'architectes
d'universitaires de chercheurs de
bailleurs sociaux
on y associe des habitants et ont
construit pendant une bonne année
un concept d'habitat
inter-générationnelle solidaire un an
entre le début de cette conception et
puis ses premières expérimentations mais
on l'a fait avec toutes ces personnes on
a réussi à construire ses résidences
dans lesquels on trouve des logements
qui soit à la fois confortable
ergonomique
non stigmatisant par classe d'âge et les
résidences dans lesquels on peut
intégrer des lieux d'échangé de partage
de convivialité
peut-être plus fort on a imaginé un
métier de gestionnaire animateurs ou
animatrices des femmes des hommes qui
facilite ce lien ce lien
intergénérationnel entre les habitants
d'un même lieu de vie
ouvert sur le quartier et les gens dans
ses résidences
ils ont la possibilité d'offrir de
recevoir de participer à un club de
créer une activité
bref de devenir acteurs de leur lieu de
vie et par conséquent acteurs de leur
vie
ça fait sept ans que l'entreprise existe
et qu'on a mis en oeuvre ce dispositif
d'habitat intergénérationnel solidaire
sur 25 résidences environ et que nous
accompagnons 1500 familles soit plus de
3000 habitants avec un impact social qui
est bien plus fort alors l'habitat
intergénérationnel c'est quoi le mieux
c'est que ce soit les habitants qui nous
l'expliquent des moins jeunes âge de la
personne
avec qui je parle et des fois je me
rends pas compte parce que
moi je vous vois j'aime vous voyez avec
mon âge quoi je suis plus épanouie et je
sors beaucoup commencent étaient
toujours enfermés
bon j'ai connu cette certaines personnes
ça nous amène quand même quelque chose
on m'a préparé mais autrement
non là je sors je vais ici après on va
promener en fait des tas de choses
pendant tout seul on ne peut pas le
faire on va reprendre la danse il ya la
base c'est bien là il ya du transport il
ya deux ans au real de macao au sein du
pays a des choses moi tout seul
cuisiner plus maintenant je deviens
l'association leur cuisine j'ai plus de
notre appel de portage de repas les
supprimer sa fin on a tous le sourire
on vient là on oublie tous ses biens
c'est ça qui est beau je suis tout seul
c'est ma famille c'est ma deuxième
famille c'est que les rencontres de
familles dans leurs boissons leur
famille suppose une 62
mais moins d'un an j'ai les jeunes les
piges dans de nous ça donne la pêche
alors en 2015 après avoir expérimenté ce
dispositif en milieu habité
j'ai découvert des nouveaux métiers
aménageurs promoteurs et j'ai compris
qu'il pouvait être aussi être exercés
par des humanistes et oui réaménagé
adapté réhabiliter le logement
d'aujourd'hui concevoir construire
développer la ville et les territoires
de demain
c'est bien entendu intégré des nouvelles
technologies de la domotique du
numérique c'est faire de nos villes des
villes intelligentes et connectées qu'on
appelle aujourd'hui smart city mais
c'est aussi c'est pas contradictoire
penser la place de l'humain dans c'est
ensemble que nous construisons qu'il
nous faut penser le handicap les
difficultés la vieillesse il nous faut
penser des lieux des changes des lieux
de partage avec eux on a développé plein
de sujets on a une vingtaine
d'opérations en cours et sur ces 20
opérations les toutes premières qui
seront livrés dans votre région une à
marseille et l'autre à aubagne avant la
fin de l'année et là c'est à nouveau des
milliers d'habitants citoyens qui sont
concernés voilà vous l'avez compris
c'est que le début du parcours mais
l'habitat intergénérationnel solidaire
c'est quelque chose maintenant qui est
une réalité pour tous les acteurs du
logement et je pense qu'on y a un peu
contribué
et puis j'espère que mes grands mères
sont un peu fier de moi aussi alors pour
terminer une conclusion en trois points
le premier j'ai 60 ans je peux donc
témoigner
il n'y a pas d'âge pour entreprendre
donc si vous avez des projets qui font
sens pour vous et pour la société
allez-y foncez perdez pas de temps
la seconde mais vous l'avez compris
l'habitat pour moi il est
intergénérationnel participatif inclusif
solidaires il est donc trop important
pour le confier aux seuls spécialistes
aux seuls experts
il faut qu'on s'y mette tous pour
construire ensemble des lieux de vie à
l'image de nos rêves
enfin c'est pas ce n'est pas une
contrainte ce n'est pas une obligation
mais c'est une chance
c'est un bonheur que de pouvoir vivre
ensemble une relation humaine pleine
avec toutes les générations et notamment
avec nos vieux alors allés vers eux
échanger partager
et puis dites leur que vous les aimez
voilà je remercie ma famille au nom de
tout ça et puis les partenaires
évidemment avec laquelle nous
travaillons jeu je vous souhaite à vous
tous à vos enfants ainsi qu'à vous aider
de vivre longtemps mais surtout de vivre
pleinement et de vous donner les moyens
d'avoir la chance de vieillir
sereinement avec les personnes qui vous
aime
voilà je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]